good day and welcome I'm Jack Van Horn
from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this
edition of our 2022-2023 foundations of
biomedical data science seminar Series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health
Institute of Virginia the UVA brain
Institute the College of Arts and
Sciences the school of data science and
through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series is focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to differing themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences
The Chosen theme for this year is data
science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we'll be enjoying
presentations from the leading thinkers
on the issues promises opportunities and
hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of the
covid-19 virus these include delayed
Health checkups and treatments mental
health drug abuse violence increased
obesity and the long lingering health
effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus indeed our
2022-2023 application cycle remains open
until the end of January and we
encourage Junior faculty members working
in areas such as infectious diseases
epidemiology clinical medicine
population Health as well as in data
science machine learning AI statistics
and other relevant domains please
consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program we're
characterizing the secondary health
effects of covid-19 necessitates unique
quantitative approach but also new
interdisciplinary collaborations
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program
we'll leverage these presentations as
vital material for our culminating
in-person Grant project development
Workshop to be held at the lodge at St
Edwards Park in Seattle Washington in
June of 2023.
today I am delighted to welcome our
speaker Jennifer Ahern associate Dean
for research and Chancellor's professor
at the University of California Berkeley
School of Public Health
Dr Ahern is an associate Dean as I
mentioned and she earned her bachelor's
degree uh in uh Bachelors of Arts in
human biology from Brown University in
1997. she completed her masters of
Public Health and doctoral degree in
epidemiology at the University of
California Berkeley in 2000 and 2007
respectively she is currently president
of the executive committee of the
society for epidemiological research she
examines the effects of Social and
physical environment and programs and
policies which alter the social and
physical environment on many aspects of
Health including violent substance abuse
mental health gestational Health Etc she
has a methodological Focus to her work
including the application of causal
inference methods and semi-parametric
estimation approaches aimed at improving
the rigor of observational research and
optimizing Public Health Interventional
planning research is supported supported
by a new innovator award from the
National Institutes of Health the office
and direct from the office and director
at the NIH and uh recently she was named
as a Chan Zuckerberg biohub investigator
in continuing our 2022 2023 biomedical
data science seminar series theme
Jennifer's lectures today is entitled
leveraging big Health Data to answer
questions about program and policy
effects Jennifer is going to present on
her research leveraging Big Data Health
uh information to understand the impacts
of different forms of violence on health
and health disparities in the state of
California and the effects of programs
and policies which may influence
violence our presentation will focus on
examining the injuries and deaths due to
Legal intervention amongst young people
and the examination of the effects of
gun shows on firearm injuries in the
post-implementation period of
California's 1999 gun show legislation
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via YouTube and
if you're watching via YouTube thank you
so much for joining us also our
specially selected 2022 2023 biomedical
data science Innovation lab participants
and alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have via the zoom chat
sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that Jennifer welcome
and thank you so much for doing this for
us we are really looking forward to your
lecture
wonderful thank you so much Jack that
was a lovely introduction
um I will just jump into it
um you now have a great sense of what I
will be talking about today
um I do want to call out that I will be
talking about as Jack mentioned uh
various forms of violence
um and so if that's a you know a
difficult topic for you this this may
not be the best to talk to join and you
know of course feel free to take breaks
as we go along as you need
so to give some sense of what I'll cover
today talk a bit about violence as a
health problem
and I'll talk about the research we've
been doing within that realm with a
couple of examples and wrap up with some
discussion and and sort of the future
directions that we're thinking about for
this work in my research program
it's probably obvious to all of you just
from sort of day-to-day life looking at
the newspaper and so on the violence is
really a very devastating health problem
in the United States
um we're often most aware of this due to
the most high profile incidents that
tend to to make the headlines such as
police violence mass shootings and hate
motivated violence all of which have
been unfortunately increasingly common
in recent years but it's also important
to remember that the largest burden of
violence is actually
um you know those those events that are
somewhat less high profile less obvious
perhaps
um in the form of General Community
violence self-directed violence and also
domestic violence
um so let's just take a little minute to
put violence in the context of sort of
burden of disease burden of mortality in
the U.S
um this figure shows
um
the leading causes of death in the
United States in recent years
and as you might anticipate we have
heart disease at the top followed
closely by cancer you can see for 2020
covid-19 coming in there at number three
and in terms of injury related causes of
death
um really the only one making this top
10 list is the unintentional injuries or
also known as accidental
injuries
um
but this overall burden sort of masks
some important heterogeneity
um that that makes violence a somewhat
unique
um contributor to our burden of
mortality
um and so now this is the the top five
uh leading causes of death
um you can see that along on the left
side and then along the top we have the
different age ranges of the population
and while you can still see
unintentional injury as playing the
primary role in mortality for those at
Young ages from the age of one all the
way up through 44.
um you also can start to see the
violence related causes of mortality
coming in the top
um top two three and four positions for
children as young as one
um going all the way up into mid 40s and
so we can see violence related causes
playing a major contribution to
mortality that we think about as being
perhaps premature or coming early in the
life course when it may be
um
uh very devastating for those affected
in their families
um so violence is an interesting area to
do research in
um for a variety of reasons uh violence
has generally been framed societally as
an issue that we handle with criminal
justice and law enforcement but I think
there are a lot of valuable things that
health or public health approach can
bring to this that I'll get to in a
moment
um another important piece of this is
that research on violence is very highly
politicized due to the connection with
guns or firearms
um there's a whole bunch that could be
said here but just to highlight a few of
the issues
um since 1996 when the Dickie amendment
was passed there's been a dramatic
curtailment of research on violence it's
a Prohibition on the use of federal
funds to Advocate or promote gun control
which of course doesn't directly say
research but they've been interpreted
essentially as um you know intended to
curtail work on on violence and
specifically gun related violence
overall and was interpreted as such by
many of the funding agencies in addition
there's the T heart amendment that since
2003 has limited data on Firearms trace
and that's has some implications for
research it actually creates more law
enforcement challenges than research
challenges
um but despite all these sort of
complexities and challenges I think
um being sort of in the among the parts
of society trying to deal with the
question of violence I think uh health
approach or health lens has really led
to some very interesting and productive
additions to how we are addressing
violence some examples are um prevention
approaches that address the contagion
aspect of violence such as
community-based violence interruption or
hospital-based Interruption a variety of
policy approaches to restrict means and
de-escalate situations such as waiting
periods
a lot of really interesting work around
modifying the environment such as
reclaiming vacant Lots creating positive
spaces in communities to try to reduce
violence and then of course in public
health we think a lot about looking
Upstream to the more fundamental causes
that may be driving violent interactions
and these 10 to be very sort of
fundamental things such as economic
opportunities education and so on
so that's a sense of violence as a
health problem and now I'll talk a bit
about the research I've been doing in
this space
um
so the vision I had for this this
started back around 2013
was that if I could develop a sort of
robust data infrastructure that would
allow me to capture and measure events
of violence in the society
that having that sort of Base uh base of
um robust data would allow research to
be built upon that could that could help
us identify
um the things that are driving violence
and perhaps identify effective
interventions when this started I was
focused on California
um with the um and that was on with a
NIH director's new innovator award
funding and then fortunately recently we
received funding from the trans
Zuckerberg by a hub investigator program
that will allow us to continue this work
as part of that we are you know
expanding both to you know some more
national uh Geographic scope as well as
digging into some new kinds of data
sources that can be leveraged
so to say a little bit more about what
these data look like we've been building
this health database from Statewide data
in California from 2005. forward you
know right now we're sort of in the 2000
2021 Zone approximately in terms of the
data we have in hand
and this includes mortality records from
the California Department of Public
Health their office of vital statistics
and then hospital system data
specifically emergency department and
inpatient Hospital data and these are
the discharge records that we get from
the California's Department of Health
Care access and information
um we're working now towards some more
National sources as I mentioned such as
National crime data and mortality data
we've been doing some interesting new
work using Google Health Trends data
so how do we use these sources to
measure violence uh while we have the
deaths from the mortality records and
injuries from those treated in hospitals
and then among those records we use the
ICB codes they're known as e-codes or
external cost of injury codes to
identify
the source of the injuries so whether it
was due to
um you know an assault type of
interaction or if it was self-directed
and those sorts of details to be able to
capture and measure the the rates of
different forms of violence so we
coordinate the sort of event-based data
I guess you could call it with the
denominator data from the different
Geographic and demographic units from
the ACs and so we then have counts and
rates of a variety of different forms of
violence related injuries and deaths
um for you know a wide range of
geographical and temporal scales
okay so I'll share a couple of examples
of projects we've done using these data
to give you a sense of the kind of uh
work we've been doing what its value is
and um you know sort of what we're
thinking about moving forward
so some of the work we do I think of as
uh sort of investigating patterns or you
might call it more descriptive
um it's very
um really allows to sort of monitor the
burden of uh violence-related injuries
and deaths in the population over time
by demographics it's been very valuable
for both generating ideas for things
that might Merit research and also for
putting the findings that we have for
more analytical projects into context
um and so I've I find this to be
actually quite an interesting piece of
what we do
um we've so we've looked at temporal
demographic and other patterns in
community violence suicide and self-harm
as well as
Police use of force related injuries and
deaths
and I thought I'd share a bit more
detail on one example project looking at
injuries due to Police use of force
among Children and adolescents in
California
so some background on this
in the past few years I would say it's
become much more broadly to people's
attention that police violence is really
critical issue impacting
populations in the U.S and we know that
these experiences are associated with
adverse Health both of course at the
moment of injury but also throughout the
lifetime
um exposure during this early period
childhood and Adolescence may be
particularly harmful
um and at the time we did this work
there was uh only one other study that
looked at injury burden among Youth and
a lot of the
um studies were sort of limited in the
sense that you know with small numbers
it's hard to
um break the rates down into
combinations of for example race and sex
and so with our large data resources we
thought we'd probably have something to
add to our understanding of this the
burden of injury because we're able to
look at all of these very finely divided
up groups
um the work to date had documented the
mechanisms through which youth come into
contact with the police through
structural marginalization and had
documented stress-related Health
outcomes such as impacts on Mental
Health that result from
these sort of violent interactions with
police
and so here's one of the findings from
the paper this shows the rate of
um what's called the ICD code is legal
intervention injuries so it's injury due
to an interaction with law enforcement
and this is injuries through the
emergency department as well as
inpatient hospitalization
and this is among youth so um people age
0 to 19. and these are the rates over
time
um and split up by race ethnicity groups
and so what probably jumps out most
obviously here is the dramatically
higher rate of injury due to law
enforcement experienced by black youth
and as I mentioned we're also able to
divide this up by different combinations
of demographics and so we're now looking
at the overall rate
um over that time frame but we've
divided it by age groups so the cop
panel shows us the younger
um age group the 10 to 14 year olds
while the bottom panel shows us the the
older adolescence the 15 to 19 age group
um
and we can again see the um the pattern
that we observed in the prior plot of um
black children being much higher having
a much higher rate of injury due to
Legal intervention but it's also
interesting here to see particularly if
you focus on the younger children and
the top panel that you can see the rate
for black boys of course is the most
elevated but the rate for black girls is
actually very high and higher than that
for any of the other groups whether
you're looking at boys or girls and so
this just really shows the differential
impact of this form of Violence by race
ethnicity
in a way that's obviously going to be
very harmful and needs attention
um and so overall we conclude we're
seeing that
um the rate among Youth Of course is
much lower than it would be among adults
um but there is quite a degree of
differential impact across these
demographics and in particular black
children and adolescents a much greater
burden of injury than youth from other
racial ethnic groups
um it's also notable that if we think of
the comparison to White youth there are
a lot many groups that have higher rates
um black youth of course but also
American Indian Alaska native Hispanic
and other and multiple race all had
higher rates than those of white
children
and having these large data allowed us
to really dig into intersections between
race sex and aged and this revealed this
somewhat unique impact among black girls
um and you know this is
um something that's consistent with work
in the past that's documented uh what
could be thought of as adultification of
black girls
um and the perception of them as more
threatening
so that's one example of the kind of
work we can do we have done
descriptively looking at patterns of
different forms of violence
and now I'll shift into talking about
work we do looking at how the physical
and social environment and policies and
programs impact different forms of
violence
um in some of this we've looked for
example at more local things such as
local violence prevention programs that
are trying to reduce Community violence
we've looked at some sort of Statewide
phenomena policies
um and I'll provide one example today
um one part of starting to work with
these data is
um I'm not sure you know sort of what
disciplines are represented by folks
watching the talk but in epidemiology
our sort of standard study designs tend
to be you know cohorts following people
individuals over periods of time that
sort of thing
um and these are very different sorts of
data um and so working out what would be
the most effective ways to work with
them and still have strong
interpretation of results for analytic
Studies have been part of our kind of
Journey
um and you know we've come up with a
used a whole bunch of different methods
depending on exactly what we're doing
but some examples are here
um and so that's been another
interesting piece of this
so the example study I I thought I'd
share today
um is you could think of it as sort of a
intersection between looking at a change
to the physical environment and um
looking at a policy effect
um and this is looking at the
relationship between gun shows and
Firearm related deaths and injuries
and the effects of those on Californian
populations
um so for some background
um gun shows for those who may not be
familiar with them
um they're events that set up uh sort of
temporarily over usually over a weekend
um and offer a temporary source of new
and used Firearms ammunition and related
equipments tend to be setting up in
convention centers or Fairgrounds there
are over 4 000 annually in the U.S
they're a relatively small portion of
animal firearm sales estimated between
four to nine percent but they tend to be
uh or they can be dependent on where
they are exactly places where they're
somewhat left less oversight and guns
purchased or acquired here are
disproportionately implicated in crimes
and when we did this work there had been
very limited research on gun shows and
Firearm injuries
um this one paper by Duggan looked at
um
the relationship in California and Texas
and found there was no connection
between gun shows and Firearm injuries
and deaths but you know then in sort of
their probably their worst nightmare
scenario they get a variety of
commentaries on the problems with this
study and so among the problems were
that they had incomplete assessment of
gun show events that they were
underpowered and quite importantly that
they had ignored the 10-day waiting
period in California so they were
essentially looking at outcomes at a
time when the guns would not yet have
been acquired by the people purchasing
them
so we thought in a variety of ways that
we could do better and so we sort of
went from there and tried to look at
this question
um more rigorously
we thought that it was certainly
reasonable to think gun shows May
increase firearm injuries but also that
it might be interesting to look at
whether we could see any effects of the
differences in State Firearm regulations
and that that might modify the
relationship between gun shows and
Firearm injuries
there's quite a lot of work showing how
there are flows of firearms from less
restrictive to more restrictive States
and that that you know of course limits
the effectiveness of in-state
regulations of people just travel out of
state and so we thought we might be able
to see some effect of this in the
setting of the gun show
so our objective was to look at whether
gun shows were related to short-term
increases in firearm deaths and injuries
in the nearby regions and to look at
whether this differed by the state in
which the gun show was taking place
and so
um we sort of leveraged the natural
variation in the timing and location of
gun shows that were taking place both in
California and then in our neighboring
state Nevada you can see we share quite
a lot of our border with Nevada
um we used a difference in differences
approach to look at this question and so
I'll walk through the pieces of these
differences
the first was looking at the rates of
firearm deaths and injuries in the two
weeks before each gun show and comparing
that to the two weeks after each gun
show and accounting for the 10-day
waiting period in the case of the
California shows
so that's for California shows
um
within a traveling distance around the
show I'll talk a bit more about how we
Define the distance
and then we made this comparison
um the entire time looking at California
populations but looking at California
populations exposed to gun shows in
California versus California populations
exposed to gun shows taking place in
Nevada and so in Nevada there's really
two primary locations Reno up near where
the figure is here and then also Las
Vegas where there are a substantial
amount of shows very close to the border
with California
um the decision of the two-week window
before and after was really motivated by
wanting to have a really sort of tight
um tight time around the show to avoid
there being other things that might be
changing during that time frame um but
we also checked the sensitivity of the
results to bigger and bigger and smaller
time Windows around the show
so the way we're thinking about this
design is that each region is serving as
its own control because we're comparing
rates immediately before and after the
show where you know very little else
will have changed within that very short
time frame if we keep the geography the
same
so that was our general design and then
we needed a source of data for the gun
shows themselves the locations and dates
and so we first thought we would
approach this using a sort of uh I don't
know fancy high-tech approach and we
went
um to the internet and thought we could
use sort of web scraping approaches to
identify past shows we used the Wayback
machine to restore old versions of
websites that had posted dates and
locations of gun shows
um and this seemed to be working
reasonably well
except that when we went
um to try to compare what we were able
to get
um from the internet to sort of more
old-school approaches of just looking
through uh gun show magazines which is
where
um you know all the dates and locations
are posted we found that our assessment
was incomplete and in particular that as
we were going further back in time we
were losing more and more of the gun
show events relying on the internet
so uh we decided we need to rearrange
our approach and go a little lower back
to start with
and so in doing this we started with the
physical gun show magazines as the
primary source
and we had access to these because a
colleague my colleague Aaron went to
mute at Davis had for many years been
subscribing to these magazines and had
been storing them in a place that he
calls the shed which sits behind his
office at UC Davis
and in the picture is Krista and Garen
Krista work worked with me at the time
and she also lived out there near Davis
so she went and picked up this giant
giant bins of magazines and brought them
to us at Berkeley to start working with
them
before they could Venture into the sheds
there was an issue of black widow
spiders that had to be dealt with but no
one was well I suppose some spiders were
probably harm but no people were harmed
in the recovering of the journals from
the shed
that's Ellie who's the first author on
this work working in the you know the
copy room with all of these magazine
scanning
then she had to convert it all over to
being you know readable characters uh
did a whole bunch of work to clean up
the addresses and after all of that work
we had somewhat over 900 gun shows over
our time frame
in both California and Nevada
so we have our gun shows we have our
outcome rates before and after them and
then we needed to Define our uh sort of
geographic
uh range around each show and so what we
decided to do was create a unique region
that we determined to be exposed to the
show based on the sort of zip codes
around each show
and we decided that for the California
shows
um people would probably be willing to
travel about an hour uh to get to a show
but probably not a lot more and this is
because it based on the geographic and
temporal distribution of shows If you're
willing to drive about an hour there
will be a show you can get to within a
couple of weeks at any given time and so
it seemed unlikely that people would go
a whole lot further if there'd be in
most instances if there would be another
show you know a week later or so
um we thought that for the shows in
Nevada
um there might be a willingness to go
somewhat further uh there's shows in
Nevada have quite a lot of differences
in terms of what you're able to acquire
there and the types of regulations that
um are or are not present
um and so we thought about two hours was
reasonable for how long people might
travel to get to a show in Nevada
um and so as I previously noted we're
looking at the rates in these Geographic
zones Within These driving distances uh
two weeks before and after each show and
for California that two-week window
starts after the 10-day waiting period
concludes
uh we used a pretty straightforward
regression modeling approach
um with random effects on the show's
month indicators and a population offset
an estimated rate ratios associated with
the gun shows in California shows in
Nevada those are both the sort of first
difference and then we compared the two
to each other for the difference in
differences comparing the Nevada shows
to the California shows
our main question was just about overall
firearm injury but we also stratified by
different types of firearm injury to see
if there were any revealing patterns
there
so here are main results you can see
that the adjusted rate ratio for the
California shows is very much on the
null there's no elevation in the rate of
firearm injuries and deaths after
California shows
however there's quite a substantial
elevated rate of gun related injuries
and deaths following Nevada shows
and you know with one null and the other
about a 70 percent increase rate the
difference in differences estimate is
also approximately a 70 percent
increased rate comparing the Nevada gun
shows to the California Ventures
and when we divided the analysis to look
at self-directed interpersonal and
unintentional firearm injury we found
the strongest associations were present
for the interpersonal
um violence-related injury but that
there were elevations in the rate for
all of the forms
um
of firearm injury
all right so what do we make of all of
this
um it could be that California which has
quite strict regulations around gun
shows may be deterring firearm
acquisition and whatever you know
activity was planned based on that
firearm acquisition while the Nevada's
regulations which
um are very minimal and it did not and
that there's of course a huge amount
that could be said here but some
examples of differences between the
states California requires Universal
background checks and has a very large
and comprehensive set of gun show
regulations that are strongly enforced
Nevada does not regulate much of
anything around gun shows and we know
from other work that legal activity is
much less common in states that have
these types of regulations of the shows
compared with
um places that do not
um another
um possible explanation is that we're
seeing some displacement so because
California's strict regulation means
certain things sort of can't be achieved
at uh California gun show it may be
motivating travel to Nevada
um for acquisition of certain Firearms
or types of ammunition or whatever might
be of interest that's simply not
available in California and there is
quite a lot of work documenting gun
trafficking between our these two states
now of course this is a you know this is
an observational study we've done
everything we can to try to make
um you know sort of eliminate other
explanations by uh looking you know
comparing each region to itself very
short time frame uh before and after
but of course there could be some other
source of bias like uncontrolled
confounding
we did a lot of work to try to convince
ourselves that that was not very likely
for example we did a negative control
analysis where we looked at non-firearm
injuries and deaths as the outcome in
all of those results were null which was
reassuring that there wasn't some other
source of bias
we also did a quantitative bias analysis
to try to figure out if there were some
unmeasured confounder how would it need
to behave what kind of confounder would
it need to be and essentially it would
have to be quite a strong confounder it
would have to be somehow following the
same Geographic and temporal
distribution of the gun shows very
uneven between California and Nevada and
changing markedly in the weeks before
and after the shows so that's the sort
of thing those are the properties it
would have to have and there's nothing
that we were able to think of that would
have had those
properties
so in conclusion it seems like
California's policies regulating uh
firearms and gun shows may be quite
effective in preventing acute increases
in farm injuries and deaths and it is
important to remember that's really all
we're doing here by focusing on the
Windows right before and after it's just
acute changes
um it would be interesting to look at
this in other settings where you have
states with
um you know stricter and less strict
firearm environments to see whether
similar types of phenomena are taking
place
of course better understanding in
general of patterns of acquisition and
use of firearms are needed and this is
just one small piece of a very complex
puzzle that is firearms and Associated
injuries in the U.S
all right let me just see how I'm doing
on time it's okay
um so a few points for discussion before
we go to the Q a
um we're continuing to develop
approaches uh to work with these you
know health related Big Data
um with novel analytic methods to study
questions about different forms of
violence and as I noted some of this is
kind of in the health monitoring
hypothesis hypothesis generation realm
and then the other piece is trying to
really generate evidence from these
observational data that can help us
understand what programs and policies
might be effective at mitigating
different forms of violence
we're working towards expanding to
National scope and broadening the
sources we're using
these are just a few of projects that
are sort of somewhere in between
upcoming and underway looking at gun
stores and sales and gun related injury
also alcohol Outlets some of that work
is actually uh just come out in a health
in place if you want to check that out
um
we have worked underway looking at
marijuana policy changes and violence
pandemic related changes in violence
have been very interesting
um and then a variety of other
continuing investigations into people's
injuries due to law enforcement
interactions
um I think some of the things we've
gleaned from working with these type of
data is that once you have this sort of
basic infrastructure in place
um you can have very sort of time and
cost efficient use of those resources
because you know we do put a lot of work
into making them getting them ready to
use but once that's been done the data
are at the ready and then can can be
combined with other efforts that may be
more time intensive or detailed such as
the work that we did Gathering gun show
data and also other work that's underway
on more kind of detailed local policy
assessments where that can now be
coordinated with data that are are ready
to go
um obviously having you know the general
population data um allow us to have
estimates that are very applicable to
the areas under study it's a complete
population data
and having the very large
numbers particularly you know California
is an enormous State
um allows us to really divide up the
data into lots of different population
subgroups that may be of interest and
important for understanding Health
disparities uh where in settings if we
had
[Music]
um
smaller smaller general population data
that we might not really be able to
report reliable rates and so having
these large data has been really
beneficial
yeah
there are lots of things that would make
things better for us one would be
increasing the timeliness of data
availability California actually does a
great job of having these um Statewide
resources coordinated and available for
research but the process is for
acquiring them can be you know time
consuming and you know we there's quite
somewhat of a lag certainly a couple
year lag between
um when you know events are occurring
and when we can actually be looking at
the data
another interesting area we've been
working on is more linkages among these
data sources and I think this is going
to be a really fruitful exciting place
for a lot of new work we've been working
on some of these for example linkages
between birth files with hospital
records and
um also amongst hospital records to
understand you know events that preceded
later violence related injuries so I'm
really excited about this area we've
been investing a lot in this linkage
space
so that's what I had to say to all of
you today
um this is you know I'm sort of the
representative of a huge collaborating
group that's worked on this
um I couldn't none of this would have
happened if it weren't for all of the
folks uh acknowledged here uh
collaborators at Berkeley also many
other places to Emperor to UCSF NYU
Colombia Davis
um and of course all of our funders have
been critical uh to making this possible
so that's what I've got and uh happy to
take any questions
Jennifer thank you so much for sharing
all this with us this is uh this is a
lot of work that you guys have done I
thank you for sharing it with us I'm
kind of curious if you
have look you mentioned
um kind of looking at the kind of
interaction if you will between guns and
and Alcohol and Other say drugs I'm
curious because you have Nevada in your
equation of course Nevada is famous for
many things one of which is the gambling
industry and I noticed that two of your
major locations that you were looking
for gun shows were both in Reno and Las
Vegas which are kind of destination
you know locations for people to they
may not necessarily reside in Nevada but
they may go to Nevada to go to Reno for
the entertainment gambling industry you
know going to shows and uh you know
Cirque du Soleil or whatever it is at
the same time is there may be gun shows
I'm curious if you have looked at any of
those other factors that sort of
differentiate Nevada from California
yeah that's a really great question
um I don't think we have
um essentially there's complete
um co-occurrence if if you know what I
mean you know like those two areas just
are are characterized by a pretty
substantial
gambling industry I guess argue
certainly Las Vegas may be more more
than Reno but both you know both have
um that is a big Focus
um so we haven't but that's a really
interesting question I have to give some
thought to
um how we might be able to dig into that
more but yes there are so many
differences between the two states
[Laughter]
yeah this is just one of many but uh I
was just kind of curious about that and
I'm also curious about
um the role of things like the various
State and National say Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms or something as a
potential source of data or other
information that might be helpful for
you as you're pursuing some of these
activities
um
yes so there the work that I was just a
few slides back I mentioned that um
where we looked at uh firearm
stores and Firearms sales connected to
firearm injuries
um that was in collaboration I'm gonna
now get I'm I probably can't remember
the correct name but this is sort of the
California
um version of you know that sort of
agency that oversees firearms and
um it's been a little bit tricky they
had had provided data but then declined
to provide more data and it's not super
clear exactly what's going on there but
at any rate we have data for um I think
it's about eight or ten years of time
and so we were able to use those data to
coordinate with the health health
related violence data that we've talked
about and that was how we were able to
look at the relationship between
uh firearm
stores and sales from those stores
related to farm injuries
um
maybe I mean if data is the you know the
Grist for this Mill and uh one of our
listeners was asking about how you
um also apply Google data for some of
your work and if you could say a little
bit more about how you do that um yeah
yeah I'd love to say say a little more
about that so
um we were so what we were we may do
more but what we've done so far is we
were interested in whether we could use
the Google Health trans data to capture
some of what might be going on with
domestic violence over the period
um where the pandemic hit because we
were very worried that all of the kind
of usual ways of monitoring
uh something like say child maltreatment
would suddenly be impacted so for
example children are not physically
going to schools in many cases
and so they're not you know there's no
teacher to see you know if they seem to
be
having experienced an injury or whatever
the situation might be
um and so we thought you know we we
can't really rely on the usual types of
data sources and so we wondered whether
we could use Google search data so
essentially it's
um
you
um
you come up with
um
a sort of set of Search terms that
you're going to use to try to see the
volume of search on a certain topic and
to use that to monitor that you know
it's obviously not directly capturing
the phenomenon but whether whether it
could be a way to capture some aspect of
the phenomenon um there's a paper that
we had come out I think in maybe just
the last year led by Kristen Newman
um I think it was an American Journal of
epidemiology that did a really nice job
outlining our strategy to to go through
the search term refinement process which
you know it was one of those things that
when we started it we sort of thought oh
no problem we'll just you know get in
there and grab the search data and go on
our merry way and it turned out just the
process of figuring out how to come up
with the Search terms and all of that
was kind of the bit one of the big most
challenging pieces
um
of
uh working through the process
I would say in addition probably the
biggest asterisks I would put around
working with a Google Health Trends API
data is that what you receive out of
um the sort of the outcome or the the
search information that you get is a
scaled relative search volume and so the
fact that it's relative search volume
really complicates things when you're
trying to look at the effects of
something like the pandemic where we
could imagine that the pandemic the
occurrence of the pandemic may have just
directly impacted people's online
behavior in a very sort of substantial
way at least possibly and so that always
sort of lurked as a challenge was
um
because we knew that we were always we
were relying on this relative search
volume metric where there could be have
been a big change in overall search
Behavior so anyway that's maybe more
that you wanted to know but Krista
Newman's paper is really fantastic
um in outlining the details of how we
went through that process and in a way
that would make it accessible for you
know someone else to sort of go in there
and try to measure their own phenomenon
Jennifer are you getting any sense of
what motivates people to want to go to
gun shows
um you know as a you're basically
they're going to the gun shows you're
collecting the data on that they've
they've come are you getting any sense
of like why and has that changed
pre-pandemic to
post-pandemic
oh that's a great question
um I mean so it's gun shows are pretty
interesting so if you think about
um
a gun show in California so California
is extremely heavily regulates a lot of
things around uh firearms and because of
the 10-day waiting period you actually
can't leave a gun show with a gun if you
purchase a gun at a gun show you would
then pick it up after the 10-day waiting
period from a nearby retailer
um and so you know it's an opportunity
for people who are interested in guns to
obviously you know physically interact
with with the guns and um you can they
can purchase ammunition
um you can leave a California gun show
with ammunition
um but you know for people where they
see guns as an important part of their
activities and lifestyle and Recreation
it's a chance to go you know check out
the latest items and you know much like
I don't know people might do for another
another topic of you know the fishing
fishing or enthusiasm and you know there
you might have
an image of what they're like but it's
sort of like a family affair you know
there's families there's kids there's
food there's entertainment it's sort of
like a you know a gathering event and
um because in California there's so much
regulation around it
um there's it's actually not too
surprising that you're not seeing
um substantial jumps in in firearm
injury immediately after them I would
say
um
the contrast is so interesting though
isn't it I mean you describe like a
family friendly atmosphere and yet the
the one of the results is the violence
that you know you're measuring or making
measurements of and I you know curious
if you know there's I don't know
something that's like a catalytic kind
of uh of a effect is coming from
you know gun guns in the news media you
know every night we turn on the news and
you know it's like oh this person was
shot or this person there was a gun
violence and we experienced that here at
UVA we uh University of Idaho is just
going through this now it's affected not
only University of Idaho but also
Washington State University other you
know school shootings around the country
and just kind of like wonder what's
what's driving this so is it video games
is it glamorizing gun violence in
Hollywood you know like what goes
somebody says you know gee you know what
I'd like to do is go to a gun show and
buy a gun and then go you know hurt
people I don't know what's what's
triggering that uh and I realize this is
I'm probably in that zone you're nervous
about but uh it's it does affect Public
Health obviously and it's something that
I'm wondering if there's something
that's causal that you can tap into
well I do want to clarify that when I'm
talking about these sort of you know
relatively uh unharmful events I'm
specifically talking about the version
of gun show that takes place in
California due to the substantial
regulation
um the story is very different in the
Nevada shows so there's very little
regulation you can purchase things like
assault rifles you can leave that day
with that assault rifle you can purchase
types of ammunition that are not allowed
in California
and there's a lot of documented activity
um
it among gun shows that are not subject
to much regulation there's research
showing there's a lot of activity that
takes place for example in the parking
lot that may be you know there's no
oversight whatsoever so
I just wanted to make sure that was
clear I'm not saying gun shows in
general are no of course yeah
you know region to region I mean what
happens in Texas is you know probably
maybe even maybe even more unconstrained
than what you're seeing in Nevada
um which also brings me to wonder you
know how does what you're seeing here do
you have any comparisons with you know
other countries not just other states
but you know like in the UK or the
European Union Asia Africa Australia
where you know there was a very famously
a big kind of gun buyback
um act thing a number of years ago now
and gun violence for the most part in
Australia has gone to you know almost
nothing and I'm just kind of curious if
you know violence in general whether
it's gun violence or anything else
that's uh you know any events or
activities if you have any way to
compare how the U.S does with other
countries
um well for well probably not for better
for worse just probably for Worse
um the United States is very unique
um we have so many guns in this country
uh our country is just simply a wash in
firearms and there is nowhere else that
is in that situation and so what happens
here really
there isn't really a comparable
certainly not a comparable amongst the
sort of um you know higher income
settings yeah and so it's hard you know
when something happens in the UK I mean
it's just the the whole the context
there just the guns are not everywhere
the way they are here so yeah the nature
of violence is quite
um
specific
the way we experience it is quite
specific to our situation
that's the truth
um what lessons did you learn from a
quantitative modeling point of view that
might be of interest to people who are
interested in kind of working with
similar data or things that you would
like to see done differently or where
can data science help play a role here
yeah that's a great question I mean uh
there's a bunch of different methods
we've found to be useful for working
with these kinds of data so
um I didn't present an example using
this method but we we've done this in a
few different studies where we use a
synthetic control approach and that's an
area that's developed with a lot of sort
of interesting data science work
bringing in machine learning into the
into the estimation of the synthetic
control
we did work looking at the relationship
between the mental health services act
in California
which is a sort of enormous
investment in public Mental Health
Services that was made based on a tax
initiated in around 2006
and
we found the synthetic control approach
to be very effective there because
um in that case we're looking at a
Statewide outcome and so then if you try
to think about you know well what other
state in the country is the best sort of
counterfactual comparison for California
it's maybe not obvious that any one
state can really serve that role very
well but the synthetic control approach
says you know you don't have to pick
just one well it analytically comes up
with the best weighted average of
possible control units that um that best
matches the sort of the pre-treatment or
pre-intervention Trend in your
intervention unit
um so that was has been really
interesting to learn about and very
productive for addressing these um
questions when you have the just big
aggregated rate type data which is often
what we're dealing with
um and another interesting approach
we've um been working on some of this
was used in the work looking at gun
stores and gun sales
is to basically convert what we have
into case Control Data I don't know how
familiar the audience is with that it's
you know an epidemiologic design where
you have
uh a set of uh cases meaning individuals
who had the outcome of interest but then
you have a sample of people that are
controls
um and essentially the controls are a
sample from the underlying cohort that
gave rise to the cases and
um we've done some really interesting
things combining our population-based
case data with Control Data from the ACs
so essentially um treating the ACs as if
it were a population I mean it is a
population study but then sampling
individuals from the ACs to serve as
controls and that's worked quite
effectively at kind of restoring an
individual
level uh data structure it's a little
Limited in terms of the covariates you
have but um I guess those are two things
I would highlight that have been really
interesting from doing this work I think
one of the impressive things about your
presentation is uh and one of our uh
viewers commented on this as well your
uh old school paper media you're looking
at gun magazines to basically accumulate
your data and do you have any other
General suggestions for how people might
deal with situations like that where you
know possibly the data is incomplete or
it's biased um but it's in magazines or
other you know not digital media and you
have to kind of go and find it what
other creative ways and creative
locations like libraries or crowdsourced
data collection you know what other
kinds of things would you think of
[Music]
um
well I mean certainly any you know print
may be the solution I mean for some for
a lot of these things there's no um easy
work around I mean that sort of we
started this thinking we could be clever
and and do this morning but in the end
there was no um substitute for what um
epidemiologists Call shoe leather work
which is just slogging through the
slogan sometimes that's the way to do it
right and getting the information I mean
for the the policy assessment work that
my colleague is doing and she's going to
coordinate it's around changes to
marijuana policy which in California
have been very I mean she's the expert
on it so my my statements are going to
be very sort of General on it but the
gist is you know obviously we've had
this shifting marijuana policy
environment and then
um there's a lot of discretion for local
um towns and cities to make their own
decisions about what they're going to
allow and not allow and so you have all
you have both uh the legalization but
then immediately all this heterogeneity
and look exactly what's allowed where
and that's of course then also shifting
with time and so she's been doing
um what you know might be called Legal
epidemiology where she's characterizing
localities based on going through
documentation of their laws
um and you know to my knowledge there's
not a super quick easy way to do that
requires you know reading reading the
laws and deciding how to classify so I
think that's so interesting too because
you know while we're on the one hand
we're just awestruck by the amount of
data that we have digitally that you
know in bio health and and epidemiology
and the various other forms of
biosciences that you know we we just
sort of have gotten used to just being
able to download terabytes of data but
on the other hand there's so much data
in a sense that's frozen in print media
and somebody just kind of has to go in
and mine it right but you have to like
literally go to that that giant building
that's on your campus it has books and
there's people there that will help you
to find stuff you know it's really kind
of interesting to be able to to think
about all the untapped potential of the
University Library I guess no it's
absolutely true
yeah well you know it does seem like a
lot more things are being digitized in
different forms so there may be you know
there may be productive things to think
about there I haven't given that a lot
of thought but it is interesting how you
know a lot of stuff is no longer just
printed it's at least been scanned or
something like that I think you know
we're catching up you know there's still
kind of a of a lag as the the interest
kind of goes backwards in time uh but
you know eventually we'll be like
looking at historical Trends in some of
these things because we now have access
to data from you know those pulled out
of the literature from
a generation or two ago that will be
interesting well Jennifer we've reached
the end of our hour thank you so much
for sharing your your work with us this
is really really important and I'm
really glad that uh you're uh at the tip
of the spear on this so thank you so
much for sharing it with us we really
enjoyed it and thank you everyone for
joining us and everyone have a wonderful
weekend and we'll see you next week